Well, good morning. Good morning. That was okay.
I think you can do better than that. Good morning. Great.
So it is great to be with you and, uh, you know,
happy Mother's Day to our mother's. Uh, you know,
I was thinking about Mother's Day, and, uh, I'm reminded of a story. My aunt,
like so many of us, she was touched with a cancer battle.
And, uh, this was a number of years ago while my grandparents were still living.
And, uh, so she was working through that cancer battle. And, uh,
she lived, uh, she lives in Knoxville, Tennessee,
as does my grandparents at the time. And, uh,
as she went through that cancer battle,
one of the things she did is she would go see her mother every day. Actually,
it was every morning. And oftentimes she would actually,
it was early in the morning,
she would get in the bed with her mother and just talk.
Now you gotta understand,
my aunt at this time was in her seventies
and my, my grandmother or sixties, and my grandmother was about in her eighties.
And so my mom asked my grandmother, Hey, what's the deal here?
And my grandmother said, Jan, you never stop being a mother.
Isn't that true? So,
whether you're a young mother or a more mature mother,
we want to honor you. We also recognize, as was said earlier, that sometimes,
um, when it comes to mothers, it gets a little complicated in families.
And so some of you don't know white how to feel about a day like today.
Here's what I want to encourage you with. We have a God who sees you,
who knows you, who loves you.
And I love the fact that the scripture over and over and over,
it gives us a picture of how we understand God.
And that's what we're talking about, knowing God. But you know,
sometimes in the Old Testament and in the New Testament,
God is described as a mother. Isn't that amazing?
So if it's complicated in your family, or if you celebrate today,
here's what we wanna say in all things.
We want to look to our Lord to give us hope and joy,
to give us comfort when it's been hard, and, uh,
to help us on our journey through life, because God has given us life.
So I wanna talk today about, uh, knowing God.
Now, I know in your handout it says that we're looking at, uh,
here come the judge. Here come the judge. Right? But here's the reality.
That's Joel three, one through 16. I thought in light of, uh,
the complicated nature of that passage, which we'll cover next week,
thought it might be good for us to get a glimpse of the end of the story.
So today we're actually looking at Joel three 17 through 21.
So if you have your Bible turned there, Joel three 17 through 21.
And in this passage we're gonna be talking about knowing God. And you say,
Heath, why are you flipping it up? Well, there are a couple of reasons, right?
Uh,
mother's Day is one of the three most attended Sundays on the planet,
right? That's number one.
So it's a complicated passage that we're gonna be looking at, uh,
in three, one through 16. And, uh,
so I want to give us the end of the story to help contextualize some of the
difficult bit bits that we're gonna handle next week.
The second thing that I want to say is, uh,
that is a long passage of scripture,
and there's a lot of things to work through next week. So, uh,
I thought I might flip it up.
This end of the story's gonna help us understand next week a little bit better.
Okay? So that's why we're doing what we're doing.
So today we're talking about knowing God. Now, if you have your Bible,
turn to three 17, and we're gonna begin reading there. And I'll,
I'll make some comments as we go.
And then I wanna offer three reflections from this passage about knowing
God. Okay? Knowing God.
So three 17 begins, and it reads this way,
then you will know that I am the Lord, your God.
Stop. Then after then, then what?
Well,
the passage is talking about after the judgment described in three,
one through 16. Uh, God judges, uh, certain groups,
and he saves other groups. So we'll talk about that next week.
But it's in that judgment and salvation
after that, when that happens, then
you, Israel will know, I am the Lord your God,
who dwells in Zion, my holy mountain. And let me stop here.
What in the world is Zion? We're you remember that old song, right?
We're marching to Z. Anybody remember that? Or is that just me? Okay,
there's like five of us in this room, awesome. Solidarity. We're together,
right? Zion, what is Zion? Zion is an Old Testament concept.
It's a place, it's the place where God dwells.
Psalm 46 talks about Zion. Uh,
Psalm 95 through 100 talks about God's
kingship and reign in Zion.
Zion is the place where God dwells.
And it's, uh, a, a, a people. That is the people of Jerusalem.
It's a place, it's a city. And in the Old Testament,
particularly in the prophets,
Zion is a city often described as a mother lady Zion.
Zion is the place that has been judged in sin,
but redeemed by God's victorious act. That's Zion.
And here Zion is saved,
delivered by the activity of God.
So once God has delivered Zion and purged it of sin,
he dwells there. So check this out, then you will know that I am the Lord,
your God, who dwells in Zion, my holy mountain,
Jerusalem will be holy. And this is an important point here.
Only God is holy.
So you're not holy. I'm not either, really?
Yeah, really.
There's only one reality that is holy and that is God.
And then what God does out of his holiness,
he makes things holy.
And what is holy in the things that God makes Holy.
It's like in the Old Testament, at the temple, uh,
God would consecrate or the other language that we use in English is sanctify,
make things holy. Another way to say that is not to say, I am holier.
That's a lot of times what we think. We think, oh,
I'm hol you're impure. I'm holier than now.
That's not the picture of holiness. Actually, in the Old Testament,
in the Old Testament, holiness is something that's fit to use.
So, instance at the temple,
God could make a shovel. Holy. Well,
why would he make a shovel? Holy, because that's the, the,
the shovel carried the ashes from the altar and put 'em in a safe
space. God could make a, uh, an altar, holy
God could make a person holy God could make a priest
holy. Only God can do that. We can't do that. Why?
Because there's only one reality that is perfectly holy, and that is God.
And what that means is pure undefiled
completely separate and unique,
that's holy,
but God confers holiness onto human beings.
See how that works? So you can see here already,
Jerusalem will be holy. Why?
Because Jerusalem is so much better than every other place. No,
it's because God has made it holy in judgment and in salvation.
See how that works? So that's what that means.
Jerusalem will be holy.
So we're talking about a time in judgment and salvation where God
reveals himself, that we will know that he is the Lord,
our God who dwells in Zion, his holy mountain,
Jerusalem will be holy. And then we see this other thing, foreigners will never,
uh, overrun it again. Now, you might be thinking, oh,
foreigners will never overrun it again, man,
God must be racist or xenophobic. Or maybe he's, you know,
this political party or that this has nothing to do with any of that.
So what you need to understand, and this is getting to next week,
so if you want to know more about this,
come next week and we'll talk a little bit more about it.
But what you need to understand is the story of Israel is the story of
invasion. That is to say, Israel,
when they got into the land,
they were constantly under threat from foreign invasion, asy,
Babylon, I mean, all sorts of other nations as well.
But those are the two biggies, asy and Babylon. Also,
Israel was under foreign occupation in Egypt. In,
in other words, they were in Egypt. And we know this from the Book of Exodus.
They were residing down there, and then they became slaves,
laborers under Egyptian thumb. And then after,
you know, a, a long period of time, they got into the land of Israel,
and they were under a threat by Assyria and then later Babylon.
And they were conquered by both nations,
at least the northern kingdom in 7 22 was conquered by Assyria.
And then the Southern kingdom was wiped out by, uh, Babylon in 5 86,
b c e. And then after that, even when they got back into the land
in 5 39 BC after they got into the land, and Cyrus, uh,
issued this decree, Israel can go back from their, you know, uh, exile.
They can come back into the promised Land. Even after that,
they were under threat from Persia and they were under foreign
occupation.
So what I'm getting at here is the story of Israel is a story where there's
always constant invasion into their land. They're always under threat
from what? From foreign powers who want to oppress them.
So it has nothing to do with xenophobia,
it has nothing to do with, uh, anti-immigration policies or anything like that.
So we gotta kind of separate what the Bible is talking about from our own
political agendas, okay?
And so what's going on here is God is saying, Israel,
you will no longer be under threat in Zion because foreigners won't under,
uh, overrun my borders. Period. Why?
Because God dwells there,
he provides perfect protection and perfect peace.
Now, verse 18 gives further clarification of that picture.
Look at it in that day,
the mountains will drip with sweet wine. Now, we've,
if you're a close reader of scripture,
you've already heard that language of sweet wine,
because it shows up earlier in the book of Joel.
I'll talk about that in a few minutes. In that days, the mountain will drip,
the mountains will drip with sweet wine, and the hills will flow with milk.
And you say, gosh, is that, uh, 2% or is that whole milk?
Well, uh, do you remember how the land of Israel is described, uh,
by God when he talks about the land, when, when Israel's going into it?
Think about the Book of Exodus and numbers and Deuteronomy.
The land of Israel is described as a land flowing with milk
and honey, sweet things, right? Milk actually,
um, you know, it,
it may be yes from all the livestock, but it's,
it's probably an image talking about fatness and abundance, just like honey is,
honey is maybe bee honey, right? We certainly have that in the land of Israel,
but it also may come from, um, uh,
fig trees and it may come from date palms. The, the, the,
the, the fruit that that's there, that's beautiful. It's delicious.
If you don't like dates, I'm sorry, they, it's good, right? Sweet.
It's delicious. But at any rate, the mountains will drip with sweet wine.
The hills will flow with milk. All the streams of Judah will flow with water.
So you have milk and you have wine, and you have water.
And more than that,
you have a spring issuing from the Lord's house watering the valley of the eks.
I'll talk about the valley of the Eks in just a minute.
Egypt will become desolate and eat them a desert wasteland because of the
violence done to the people of Judah in whose land they shed innocent blood.
But Judah will be inhabited forever.
And Jerusalem from generation to generation, I will pardon their blood guilt,
which I have not pardoned for the Lord dwells in Zion.
I'll walk us through verse 21 in just a minute.
This passage actually helps us understand what it means to know
God and I, again, three reflections.
Just wanna walk through this quickly and briefly. Uh,
I would love to spend about six hours here,
but I think you would throw tomatoes at me if you have them.
Or maybe your Bible, you just throw it at me six hours. Or maybe, you know, uh,
well, I don't know if I've shared this with you,
but I was a pastor in North Carolina, and, uh,
it was a little tobacco road church. It was incredible, uh, little church.
Most of that congregation had grown up, uh,
growing and cutting and drying tobacco, right? So a little church, uh,
called, it's not even in a town, it was called Justice Community, right?
Justice. That's a great name. So I got up to preach and, uh, you know, I said,
well, you know, I, I, you know,
one of the deacons said that I could preach for an hour and a half,
and I thought that was really generous. And this guy out in the,
and I know him now, I mean, I got to know him over my time there,
but he's in the back. And he said this, well, preacher, you can go, how long,
however long you want, but we're outta here at noon, right?
So it may be one of those things where, you know, I'm not gonna go long.
I'm really not.
But I do wanna offer some reflections here on what this text teaches us about
knowing God num number one, this is the first reflection.
Knowing God is possible. Let me say this again.
Knowing God is possible.
Now, the other day, one of my kids was almost in despair,
why? She's in, uh, getting in more advanced math.
And, uh, she's in this math and she was really frustrated.
She was working through this math problem, and I could see it.
She was getting more and more frustrated. She needed help. And so she said, dad,
help me. And so I,
being the very patient and kind father that I am, I said,
you need to figure this out on your own.
It's been a long time since I've been in seventh grade math, right?
But she was working through this problem. She didn't understand it.
And I said, you can do this. You can figure this out. She said, no,
I can't. It's not possible. It's not noble. I, I'm just,
I don't know how to do it.
She didn't think that understanding that math was possible.
She felt inadequate to the task. Now,
some of us actually have that perspective on God knowing God,
forget it. Impossible. It's not even no way.
God has more important things to do than to bother with me.
My life isn't all that significant. The man upstairs,
he's got stuff to do. I mean, like, run a world or, you know,
care for the universe or, you know, global warming or whatever it might be.
He's got more important things to deal with than measly old man.
But besides that, he's like, uh, God, how can I ever know him?
Now, I love this because this passage reminds us
not that knowing God is impossible,
but my friends knowing God is actually
possible. Have you ever had this perspective?
There's no way I could ever know God. His his ways are,
are absolutely too lofty for me. I'm just, I'm just a little worm
compared to the massive weight of divinity.
Well, here's a reality. I don't know what to tell you.
Joel three 17 reminds us that knowing God is
possible. You say he No, no. I mean,
let's go biblical theology here. And biblical theology is a fancy,
nerdy way of saying that the Bible interprets the Bible. I mean,
doesn't Paul in one Timothy say something like this one Timothy six
15 through 16, he is the blessed and only sovereign,
the king of kings, the Lord of Lords,
who alone is immortal and who lives. And listen to this phrase,
what Paul says to Timothy. He lives in inapproachable, unapproachable light,
whom no one has seen or can see to him, be honor internal power. Amen.
Oh my goodness, God dwells in unapproachable light. Nobody's ever seen him.
How in the world can we know him?
Joel three 17, what does he say?
Then you shall
know. No. And the Hebrew here,
the language in the original text here is not know about.
I mean, I have a driver's license.
You see me on Sunday, uh, you know, preaching,
and you might think I know Heath,
but I would just say your knowledge of me may be kinda like that driver's
license. It's way different than my wife who knows me
deeply, relationally.
See the kind of knowledge that's implied here than you
shall know that I am Lord your God
is not driver's license kind of information. Yes, there's Heath. He's five 10.
Yes, he has brown hair, blue eyes. Yes, I know Heath, I know God.
That's not the picture here.
What God is saying is
When he acts in judgment and salvation,
then you will understand. Listen to this,
the very heart and character of God.
You will know him, not know, know about God.
I mean, we're not brains on sticks walking about,
we're human beings and we wanna know somebody.
We want to know them personally. God is saying here,
after he works in judgment and salvation,
then you will know that I am the Lord your God. It's possible.
You know, it reminds me we've already seen this language. You will know I will,
you will know, you will know. It happens here,
but you remember where else it happens. It happens in Joel 2 27.
You will know that I am present in Israel and I am the Lord your God.
And there is no other. My people will never again be put to shame.
That's Joel 2 27.
We've seen this before and again here,
it's after God, judges and saves.
Then God's people will know the very heart and character of God.
You will know that I am the Lord your God.
I want us to rest on this phrase. You will know that I am the Lord your God.
Did you know this phrase is like a,
it's like, uh, have you ever seen a movie where, uh,
the movie is alluding to or quoting
or kind of pointing back to an old movie?
Have you ever seen that? Where you watch this movie and you think,
I've seen this scene before? Yes, you have.
Because that scene in this present movie is drawing on an older movie.
It's kind like that in the Old Testament. We call this
illusion, a l l u S I O N or echoes from other texts.
And that's what's going on here. You shall know.
Do you know where that language first appears? Exodus,
what God says to his people in Exodus, for instance, chapter six, verse seven,
he says, look, I'm going to deliver you.
I'm gonna pour out some plagues on the people of Egypt and after,
and I deliver you from, uh, Egyptian slavery.
He says in Exodus six, seven,
I will take you as my people and I will be your God.
You will know that I am the Lord your God,
who brought you out from the forced labor of the Egyptians.
You will know this is a, a disclosure formula. God says,
I am going to make myself known to you.
We see it again in Exodus 1612, where God says,
I've heard the complaints of the Israelites. Tell them, he tells us to Moses,
tell them at twilight, you will eat meat.
It's when they're complaining in the wilderness about they don't have any food.
So God sends them quail. At twilight you will eat meat.
And in the morning you will eat bread until you are full,
then you will know that I am the Lord your God. See what's going on here.
When God acts in either judgment or in this case 16,
he gives the manna and quail in salvation,
that becomes an indicator on how we understand or how
we grasp the very heart of God. We know God.
The point here is that knowing God is not
mysterious. It's possible to know God.
Now, some of you in this room are thinking, well, that's, I,
I just don't know about that. I mean, I've never heard him speak.
I I've never talked to him like audibly.
So how in the world can I know God? Well,
here's what I would say to you, my friend.
That's one of the reasons he's given us his word. If you wanna know God,
I mean know the heart of God personally,
one of the things we can say is God has given us his word that we might
know him. You say, well, I've never heard God.
Let me just ask you a question. How are we doing on the Bible reading stuff?
Because, and I'm not being judgey here.
I'm just saying God's given us his words so that we might know him.
How do we know that God is knowable?
Knowing God is possible because he said so in his word.
That's the first reflection. Knowing God is definitely possible.
Some of us might be thinking, well, God doesn't know us.
He doesn't care about us. Yes, he does.
And it's his desire for us to know him.
He wants us to know more than what movies are out there.
He wants us to know more than just how to be good at our job,
how to make money. What's the most, uh,
incredible trend on TikTok? He wants us to know more than that.
He wants us to know him. And it's possible.
This leads us to this second reflection from this passage of scripture.
Not only is knowing God possible, but look at this.
We know God by both presence and absence.
Let me say that again. We know God by both presence and
absence. You say, huh, I don't remember seeing that in this text.
Well, let me unpack this for you as I do. Let me just say this. Uh,
have you ever used this phrase, oh, yes, I know person X, Y, or Z? Oh,
yes, I I know person X, Y, or Z. Of course I do.
It reminds me of the fact that actually this is a true story.
Once upon a time,
I received a Christmas card from the President of the
United States, and I'm not kidding,
I was as surprised as you are whenever I received it.
And I thought, this is a joke. But sure enough, it wasn't.
This Christmas card came signed
to my family, from his family,
and I thought, huh, president knows me.
Feels pretty good, right? It would be easy for me, right?
To say, oh, yes, I know the president sent me a Christmas card.
Best wishes to your family from our family. Oh, yes, we're tight.
But the reality is,
I don't know this guy at all and he doesn't know me.
You know how this works.
I'm on some list and then on that list,
I got sent a Christmas card. Now it's cool,
but it would be kind of untruthful, wouldn't it? If I were to say,
I know the President, yes, he sent me a Christmas card.
Might be good in a social situation, might make everybody say, Ooh,
but it's not true. Now,
why do I tell us that story? Because there's a difference, isn't there?
Between, uh,
knowing in theory something and knowing really
somebody, it's different than the Christmas cards I get from the people. I love,
the people I'm friends with. When they send me a Christmas card, it's, man,
I was thinking about you, Heath, and thinking about your family. We,
we just want to give you an update on how we're doing. I, I love this. Uh,
the Christmas card thing, it's a little different. In the UK when we live there,
we don't get Christmas cards as much. You know what we get end of year letters.
And what happens is the people who know us, I mean, my PhD supervisor used to,
uh, do this quite a bit. Uh, he would send us, and he still does, but uh,
a little bit older now, but he,
he sends us these end of year letters and it kind of debriefs the whole year.
I think that's pretty good practice. You see the difference there,
that end of year letter's radically different than this card that the president
sent.
There's a difference between knowing somebody and just kind of putting a front
out there and saying, well, I know this person.
Why do I tell you this story?
Because knowing about God
is different than really knowing God.
God doesn't want kind of a, a presidential Christmas card kind of knowledge.
He wants to know us, and he wants us to know him.
And what we're about to look at shows us that God reveals himself in both
presence and absence. Let me look at this presence bit.
We know God by his presence amongst his people.
Look at this phrase in three 17,
God who dwells in Zion, who resides,
who sits down
and lives with his people in Zion, that's the image here.
God who dwells in Zion after judgment and salvation,
God dwells amongst his people.
God doesn't want to be a drop-in visitor to your life.
God doesn't want to be a Sunday only resident. In your experience,
God wants to live
among his people to dwell other language
gets at this idea. Think about the Johanna or John, the gospel of John.
Uh, the abiding language, same idea.
God is not kind of a, a drop-in visitor or just kind of a Facebook friend.
No, God wants to dwell with his people, his presence.
That's what Ed's talking about. Presence, the presence of God.
God longs to take up residents among us.
God's presence is with his people once they've been purified of their sin and
purged of evil. And then God dwells with us.
I want you to think about that for a minute.
What does it do to your heart to know that the Holy God who created
the universe, the galaxies,
who understands
the end from the beginning, what does it do to your heart to know?
He wants to know you and me personally,
and not just kind of at a distance level.
He wants us to dwell with him, and he wants to dwell with us.
That's an image that talks about presence.
God wants to be present in your life, in the highs, in the lows,
in the triumphs, in the tragedies.
God longs to dwell with you
and me. We know God
in terms of this dwelling, his presence,
but in his presence, there are some things that are going to be absent.
So we know God
by what is revealed in absence.
Uh, before I get to that absence bit, have you ever thought about the,
uh, benefits that accompany God's presence? The benefits?
What's it like for God to sit down and dwell in your life? You say, well,
I don't think about that. We should Joel us.
Look at verse 18, this image of, you know,
in that day, the mountains will drip with sweet wine,
hills will flow with milk. All the streams of Judah will flow with water.
A spring will issue from the house of the Lord watering the valley of the
Acacia.
What we need to understand is Joel doesn't say God wants to dwell with you,
and that's it. No,
he gives an entire verse that explains the benefits of God's presence.
And we shouldn't shy away from this.
Have you ever thought about the benefits of God's presence?
Well, here we see there's sweet wine.
We see the hills are flowing with milk, whatever that means.
We also see there's waters and springs to understand the benefits of
divine presence. We need to understand earlier in the the book,
we saw the tragedy of divine absence. Do you remember this?
In chapter one,
you had no sweet wine. This is one five, there's no sweet wine.
But by three 18, when God shows up, there's sweet wine.
In one seven, there's no vine or fig. But by three 18,
the hills are flowing with milk.
In chapter one, verse 10 through 12, there's drought. But now in three 18,
guess what? There's water flowing everywhere.
And if you don't know, if you've never been to the, the land of Israel,
I'm going again, I'm taking, uh, a, a group, uh,
I think early, God willing, early December of 2023.
It's one of my favorite places to go.
But if you've never been to the land of Israel, you gotta understand it is a,
uh, a land that desperately needs water,
right? And if water doesn't come, people die.
Especially in the ancient world,
a land completely dependent on the rains.
So if there's no water, people are dying. But in God's presence,
there's lots of water, Water, water everywhere.
It's everywhere. So what are the benefits of divine presence?
Wine, milk, water. More than this. Look at this.
A stream will come up from the temple watering the valley of,
in some of your translations, it might read shaim.
Or in the version that we're looking at the acacia.
Do you know what an acacia cre a tree is an acacia tree.
In the Middle East is a tree that grows in the desert.
You see what's going on here? God's gonna provide streams in the desert
from his presence.
There are benefits that accompany God's
presence. Maybe you feel like you're going through a drought in your life.
My friends, God's presence provides water for a thirsty soul.
Sometimes we don't like to talk about the benefits of divine presence.
Sometimes we use this kind of language. We say things like, well,
I worship God for who he is, not what he does.
And we think that that sounds spiritual.
And on the one side, I think that's right. Right?
God is not a divine gumball machine. We put in our 25 cents of faith and outs,
spits a gumball of good God doesn't work that way.
So God's not our glorified divine gumball machine.
And if you don't know what a gumball machine is, get out more. Right?
God is in a, a, a glorified gumball machine. That's true.
But sometimes we forget
that the scripture outlines again and again and again, and it does.
So in this passage, there are benefits to the divine presence in our lives.
In here. It's  fertility, beauty,
life.
I love the fact that over and over and over again,
the scriptures remind us of the benefits of following God.
Do you remember Psalm 1 0 3? I love this.
Bless the Lord, owe my soul and all that is within me. Bless his holy name.
Bless the Lord owe my soul. And what does it say? Do not forget his benefits.
And then what happens in the rest of that psalm is the psalmist starts to list
all of the benefits of God's presence.
God is her healer, our forgiver, our redeemer. God is compassionate.
He's loving. He's the giver of good gifts. God provides renewal.
He is righteous. He confers righteousness. He provides justice. He's patient.
He's long suffering. He's kind.
And those things can be experienced in your life and mind.
Likewise, Joel reminds us of the benefits of divine presence.
God provides provision, care and life.
They're benefits to God's presence.
So God is known by his presence,
but in his presence, there are some things that are gonna be absent.
So we know God by what is also absent from His presence.
We know this in verse 17.
Foreigners will never overrun his holy mountain ever again.
And what does that actually mean? In the time that he's talking about,
there will be an end to all wars. There will be no war,
war, war will be absent from God's presence.
You also see this in the next verse.
Egypt and Eden will be displaced and defeated. You see that? Check it out.
Verse 19, Egypt will become desolate at Edom, a desert wasteland.
A lot of scholars have said, well, I wonder when this is actually, uh,
pictured historically. Well, we don't really know,
but here's what I can say in the Old Testament,
Egypt is the great, uh, power of oppression. In other words,
in the memory of Israel, Egypt is over and over and over again,
pictured as the oppressor of God's people. And what about Eden?
Now, I mentioned this in 5 86 bc you have,
uh, the Neo Babylonian, uh, king Nebuchadnezzar.
He conquers the, the nation of Judah. And, uh,
in the, the memory of Israel. And you can see this, for instance,
in the book of a Obadiah in the Old Testament.
You can also see it in Lamentations four.
What you find is Edom is Israel's kind of kin brother
and Edom betrays Israel,
or in this case Judah and Colludes with the Babylonians
so that Edom can get some of the benefits of the Concord territory.
So they're,
they're known as a fraternal country
that betrays Judah.
So the fact that Edom and Egypt are defeated and never again
will they experience kind of a ancy, what does that tell us?
It tells us that, frankly, check this out,
oppression and betrayal will be absent from God's kingdom.
We also see that exploitation will be absent from God's kingdom.
We also see that innocent bloodshed murder will be absent from God's
presence. We know God by what is not present with God's presence, oppression,
greed, murder, abuse, betrayal,
and sin will not be present in God's presence because God is just kind, fair,
generous, true, holy.
And when God makes all things new in this time that he's talking about, listen,
he abolishes all the evils of the world and set the world
to rights. Mothers. I would encourage you,
if you want to help your children, remind them of these things,
remind them that God is known
by what's present in his presence, by what is absent in His presence as well.
And this is the last thought from this passage.
We know God as he makes all things new. You might be saying, well, he,
I don't know where this occurs. And you know, all things new.
I don't see that in this passage.
Here's what I would say to you in the Old Testament, especially in the prophets,
what you need to understand is the prophet set a pattern and this pattern is
picked up again and again and again.
And then it shows up in the New Testament,
particularly in the Book of Revelation.
You know that book of Revelation is often called the climax of prophecy.
But I want you to think about this.
Joel depicts a time when God judges the wicked and delivers
those. He is preserved and he does this.
And when he does this, he's gonna dwell in his holy mountain.
He's gonna make all things new. There's gonna be no more war, no more grief,
no more tears,
no more crying water will be flowing from the throne.
Does any of this sound familiar? It should
We know God
as he makes all things do.
Let me read Revelation 21 and 22.
Not the whole thing. Don't panic.
Then I heard this is verse chapter 21, verse three.
Then I heard a loud voice from the throne. Look,
God's dwelling is with humanity. And he will live with them.
They will be his peoples, and God himself will be with them and be their God.
Do you see that language? God's dwelling with his people.
He will live away every tear from their eyes. Death will be no more grief,
crying pain will be no more because of the previous things that passed away.
Then the one seated on the throne, his name is Jesus. He says, look,
I'm making everything new.
And then chapter 22, verse one.
Then he showed me the river of the water of life,
clear as crystal flowing from the Ro throne of God and of the lamb down the
middle of a city's main, main street.
The tree of life was on each side of the river, bearing 12 kinds of fruit,
producing its fruit. Every month,
the leaves of the tree are for the healing of the nations.
There will no longer be any curse.
The throne of God and of the lamb will be in the city,
and his servants will worship him. They will see his face,
and his name will be on their foreheads. Night will be no more.
People will not need the lamp of a light of a lamp on the light of the sun
because the Lord God will give them light and they will reign forever
and ever. Here's what we need to understand.
This passage in Joel is pointing us to God's ultimate
renewal of all things.
When Jesus is on the throne and he makes all things
new, do you see the similarity?
God dwelling with humanity and revelation God dwelling with his people In
Zion, new heavens,
you see the water image showing up again and again here from Joel,
and then Revelation. You see fruit and healing and forgiveness.
No curse, divine presence, absence of grief. No more tears,
no more pain. We know God
by how he makes all things new.
And the key to all of this, my friends, is found in verse five, revelation 21,
the one seated on the throne. What does he say? Behold, I make all things new.
Who is this? Jesus. How does all this happen?
That's pictured in Joel. I'll tell you, it's Jesus.
If you wanna know God, you look to Jesus.
He is the agent of salvation
who makes all things new. He can make your life new. You wanna know God,
know Jesus.
Maybe you've never experienced the reality of Jesus in your life.
Maybe you've never experienced the forgiveness that he offers.
Maybe you have never stepped across the line of faith and said,
I want to follow Jesus. I want God's dwelling to be with me.
I wanna be not alone anymore. My friends forgiveness.
Life healing is found in Jesus.
You want to know God? Come to know Jesus.